in the book we discover you do have
strategies and think people are these
like when you were making the the
documentary the porn performers oh yeah
I mean well the idea behind my my
serious weird weekends was that I would
take part in whatever world I was
investigating so I made and that was
partly just to be funny but then it
turned out to have other advantages so
in the in the episode I made about porn
performers I thought it would be quite
funny if I sort of got involved in the
world of pornography and and then and
then it was a question of how far can i
push that and so I thought well I can go
I'm I can take my clothes off and
audition for one of the for the main
adult film agents and you know and so
and so that's what I did I took my
clothes off it was you thought you
committed to Judy not completely you
know comfortable for me but I did it the
one thing the concessions I made was but
this agent has an album of Polaroids
that he shows directors who come in and
want to hire talent of course and um and
so but most of them like to do it
properly I hope I can use this term on
on TV you're supposed to get wood
to show to be able to show the directors
basically what kind of tree you have
and I and I stopped short I thought you
know what my sound recordist and
cameraman and director neither say all
my mum and the viewers at home do not
need no it didn't make the documentary
any worse
no but they don't you know what happened
as a result though we shot that early in
the process and then thereafter I would
I got the Polaroid like he gave me the
Polaroids and so I had three of them and
for some reason that carried them around
with me in my pocket and then when I was
interviewing other well other performers
for the documentary they usually came a
point during the interviews where I
would take out the Polaroid and say do
you know what i lyin DeForge in south as
well and you know in another context
that could be highly inappropriate right
you wouldn't do that in a normal
workplace have a look at that but in
that context suddenly the performers saw
me as one of them yeah and it had had a
very sort of but beguiling effect they
relaxed them and they were more
comfortable when they saw the birch that
the bush tree to compare it to no no no
willow the possibility of you the
possibility would that I had with me and
one of the other things I think does
make you unique is that when you're
filming for the next month
[Laughter]
[Music]
you